hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the other course
of his pretty long discussion and monta
loggia about the relationship between
what he initially calls the expression
or utter in slow Cuchillo and then the
word the verbum and then finally the sun
filius of the divine substance or spirit
with you know which is going to be the
father and son was going to talk about
them in chapter 44 in particular as
being the essence of each other the
esencia and we want to keep in mind as
we're as we're working through this
material that when an psalm says essence
it doesn't automatically translate to
what an Aristotelian or somebody else
might make an essence particularly when
we're dealing with the the divine the
supreme being in part because esencia
for ransom means something more than
just essence it also means being and as
we saw it in earlier videos there's a
particular sense in which he's using
this you might want to check out some of
the earlier cork had some videos dealing
with
being handsome says that in in chapter
43 as he concludes this discussion about
the father of the son that the essence
of each always exists in the other so
that makes us someone as if there's a
kind of reciprocity there and he makes
sure to tell us that that's not actually
the case he says in virtue of their
substance they are so much the same that
the essence of the Sun always exists in
the father and the essence of the father
always exists in the Sun why for there
are not different essences but the same
essence that several essences but one
essence of both that makes it sound as
if somehow they are you might say
instances of one particular essence but
again and we want to keep in mind that
essence not only means what is essential
to some some bunch of things shared in
common but also the very being on that
and when we're talking about supreme
essence that is one of the attributes of
the divine we're talking about a being
whose essence is somewhat different than
the essences that we're used to dealing
with with creative beings when we turn
to chapter 44 and some says that if we
say the one is the essence of the other
we're not straying from truth but rather
emphasizing the supreme unity and
simplicity of their common nature so we
can say that the father is the essence
of the Sun meaning the father is that by
which the Sun is what it is and we can
say that the Sun is also that but they
are both equally you could say what it
is that they are I says we can't
understand this in the same way as when
we talk about the wisdom of a man so he
wants to compare this to how created
beings which have attributes like the
ones that he's been talking about so far
like wisdom how they have that or are
what they are so am a out of human being
who
jasz wisdom is not there by wisdom right
we've talked about this before in
another court concept via what can be
said substantively about about God a
human being is wisdom to the extent or
has wisdom to the extent that they do by
participating in something else by
participating in wisdom itself which
turns out to be the supreme wisdom that
is the divine substance the Sun however
does not exist through the father by
participation or for that matter have
its wisdom by participation why not
because that would mean that the Sun
would then be like or would indeed be a
created being and when in some respect
be different from lesser than the wisdom
or the the being the essentia by which
the Sun is what it is so he says just as
the supreme wisdom is always wise to
himself so the supreme essence always
exists through himself the father is
completely the supreme essence but the
Sun is also completely the supreme
assets so they're both completely
supreme wisdom and essence and therefore
they are that threw themselves Pierce a
as Anson was talk to them so he says
that essence or wisdom which is the son
is no less perfect simply because it is
an essence born of the father's essence
and a wisdom born of his wisdom there's
a difference here between being born or
generated which is from eternity
according to an some of the Sun is co
eternal with the father and being made
or being created so this is something
that is reflecting a very important
point of traditional Christian theology
and some is trying to give it a
metaphysical import here ok so going on
from here
and some says he would be a less perfect
essence or wisdom if he did not exist
through himself were not wise threw
himself and then he says it's not it's
in no way contradictory that the Sun
both subsists and he uses the the latin
term subsisted are there as something
different than Essen or something
distinct from sa the Sun subsists threw
himself he has his being through the
father but how does he have his being
through the father in such a way that he
is not ontological II dependent upon the
father the way that created things are
upon the divine substance he is the
totality on what it is that the the
father his you know the generative
principle in this case brings into k and
say brings into being however we wanted
to express this he says just as the
father has essence and wisdom and life
in himself so that it is not through
someone else's but through his own
essence his own esencia that he exists
or has basf through his own wisdom that
he is wise and through his own life that
he lists so by be getting the son he
grants the Sun this is a key idea here
he grants the Sun to he have essence and
wisdom and life in himself and if you
want to think about how this works out
in terms of you know the metaphysics and
time there is no time before which you
know just the father exists and then the
father says I'm going to only need to
express myself something like that and
then poof there's the Sun and the Sun is
given everything that the father has now
you get you know 111 essence 1 substance
but but two persons within it instead
Anselm is saying there is this
relationship
coming from but what comes from the
father what comes from the divine
substance what comes from the Supreme
essence or the spirit he has indeed
something else like itself the creative
beings that come from it that's a
different that's a different thing that
their lesser they don't have that that
same equality but the one that does come
from it even though he is generated is
co-equal in this disrespect so he says
otherwise the being of the Father the
Son would not be the same if what was
generated from the father through this
utterance through this making a word
through this wisdom through whatever we
want to call it was not equal then what
we have here is sort of a fall and the
Sun would not be of the same essence the
same substance as the father so he says
it's contradictory the Sun bolt it's not
contradictory the Sun pulses through
himself and exists from the father since
this very power of subsisting threw
himself is necessarily handsome says
something he has from the father and
then you're getting reverts to talking
in terms of wisdom and this is a little
bit of lumen ating now he's going to
make an analogy between creative beings
which can actually work this this
analogy didn't work but he says if I
have wisdom and I teach you I am
teaching you by means of the wisdom that
I possess wisdom is created in you you
are wise in a certain respect from my
wisdom because my wisdom was involved in
the process of generating yours but if
you really now possessed wisdom it's
something in you not it may it could be
identical to be the same wisdom that
we've shared right in which case it's
very much similar to this but the wisdom
that you now possess is indeed in you
and it belongs to you it's no longer
ontologically dependent we might say
says once it existed it would exist only
through its own essence and be wise only
through itself so it is all the more
more true that the father the Eternal
Father zko eternal son subsists is wise
lives through himself has all of the
attributes all of the Supreme attributes
it is those attributes in the same way
that the father is that we talked about
earlier if you want to again confer with
that video but what can be said
substantively about God that might give
you in any of what's being talked about
now all of that said in chapter 45 he
says at the same time both of them
technically are the essence of each
other but it's better it's more of a
fitting to say that the Sun is the
essence of the Father because there is
you know this distinction of persons and
within the distinction of persons there
is a priority from father to son natural
son to father so in that respect it's
better to talk about the Sun as being
the essence of the Father he says here
we go the father has his essence from
knowing but himself just is what it what
it is it is not completely appropriate
to say that he has anyone's essence but
his own since the Sun has his essence
which is totally his own but but it also
from the father and it need the very
same essence the Father yes he can be
most appropriately said to have the
essence of the Father again keep in mind
that essence means something a little
bit more in this case than just a common
quality or even what makes a thing what
it is it includes the beating of the
thing that is what essentia includes
four handsome so I am somewhat concludes
that it is it makes more sense than
about the Sun the Amy essence of the
Father but they are technically speaking
both at the air each one is the essence
of the other in part because they
actually do share a one unity common
simple essence together of which they
are you know in relation to each other
through that distinction